george advice for young people
like yourself
well
first i was i would tell them find
what you want to become what you want to
do
and long term
use certain things maybe sometimes you
don't love but where you want to propel
yourself at the future not what your
parents your your friend wants you to
become what you you you want to become
so one once you find it
you cannot doing it by yourself
everything that our that is big
achievement in life we cannot do it
doing it by ourselves so what i would
say is second thing is
try to build up your team and try to
build up your team to be able to achieve
your goal
of people that are competent
and people that you trust
you need both competency and trust
i sell a lot of people sometime in
business for example they hire people
they
that are that they trust but they turns
out to be incompetent
so now you have to fire a friend or
otherwise your business is going down
the same problem if you do the opposite
you are you're someone that is competent
but you cannot trust is gonna it's gonna
screw you you know
so it's very important to stay away from
the negative build up your team people
you trust and that are competent
and i would say the third one is to work
to work hard to sacrifice yourself you
have to go through hell sometime but
yeah you have to see the light at the
end of it you know to
keep your dream in mind it's going to
give you the motivation to go through
the tough times nothing easy to go work
work work is nothing you can accomplish
without hard
work the fourth one i would say
to invest on yourself constantly
if you do not invest on your cell phone
whatever you are in which business and
sport the game will catch up to you
for example if you're if you become a
champion at something and you stop
improving the other guys that are trying
to be champion are going to catch up to
you
so you need to invest on yourself and
most people
most athlete they make the mistake when
they start to having money they buy
luxury stuff
and that's one thing i didn't do when i
started making money i was investing of
on traveling to new york training with
john garden and the guys to learn
what is new in the the game of jiu jitsu
i used to go in thailand train muay thai
in los angeles to perfect my boxing
skill
so instead of taking that money to buy
me jewelry cars and to do what a lot of
guys do because it's a mistake
i i invested on myself because i know
there were people coming they don't want
my place so i want i didn't want them to
catch me
and the last one i would say it seems
weird
i would say
to give back
and it's not because i'm a nice guy and
it's not that
i don't say that to look good i say that
when you you make it
it creates opportunity where you can
help certain group of people
but when i say give back not give back
to everybody to anybody give back only
to the the cause that you want i give
back
not because i'm a nice guy i'm kind of
it's kind of selfish i only give back to
the people that i want to give back
because i give back to them and i know
that if i'm more successful i'm going to
be able to give back to people i loved
the cars that that that count for me so
it's it brings me more motivation
because i don't compete
for myself anymore i compete to help
people i love in a way
so when you you reach the top in your
game you need to find new motivation if
you satisfy is the end of it your
success will go down so you need to
to find new motivation what can motivate
you you know what do you want i want to
help this so i need to to be successful
i want to
you know you need to find reason who you
what do you want to do with your success
so when i say give back it's not because
i'm not because i'm necessarily it's not
to be to look like a nice guy
to keep your motivation
to be able to
keep climbing the ladder even more